this is a production of Cornell
University
so my title today is messages from a
maverick model microbe and what I
realized is how much I believe you
enjoyed my pathology this morning I was
grateful that I had the opportunity to
think about this seminar and lecturing
today instead of other things and it was
about very grateful for that obviously
the model microbe is phytophthora
infestans and we know how order to say
also this photo which I've seen many
many many many places without ever any
attribution was from Vaughn chains from
my lap about 30 35 years ago um we know
that are tough infestans is a model
micro because soak in commune and 31 and
it's very closest friends have said so
it says so in this publication sage
advice Ellen I don't think so that's not
what actually you and I would just say
some of the reasons why I cannot first
of all I'm an introvert and for those of
you who are introverts moves an
introvert yeah okay so we don't even buy
so easily it's really hard and you heard
finish finish finish yes absolutely
crazy what's up I'll be talking like
this oh and also you know my career
really did not have a special plan it
just sort of happened so i have to say i
have had no special career goals so
there's nothing I can say that would
provide any miracles to anybody but I
have wanted to do is be a professor in a
small University I got the professor
part right never quite made a small
University and life I think some of you
my first years in the in graduate school
were sort of tough I wasn't sure that I
shouldn't be in technology and it was
interesting to to go through that
experience and I suspect that I'm not
alone in that and I think that that's
okay I have subsequently come to this
absolutely really enjoy the subject is I
find it just really really exciting and
really lot of fun so I have messages
from five top 35 states and three
categories and since i'm not giving
advice what i'm going to do is sort of
relate some things that I've learned
during the last several years in these
categories first love epidemiology and
population genetics of phytophthora
infestans short segment on humanity and
a short section on host-pathogen
interactions for I think I'm going to
illustrate sort of the Maverick
qualities of this organism but I need to
provide some context for all of this and
this is me as a diligent graduate
student some years ago and you're
probably all thinking that I'm just
looking but I'm thinking very hard
disappoint notice also that I do have
brown hair at that's be probably
thinking that maybe I was thinking about
phytophthora infestans but actually
that's not true when I was in graduate
school I was essentially a lab rat I
which the Queen house once a year and I
never got to the field and my thesis
action was really very interesting i
discovered a new enzyme that was typical
of pathogens of silence any plans some
plants produce cyanogenic glycosides a
new brightest to HCM on infection ACN is
running quite toxic and but it turns out
that many pathogens of these plants
produce an enzyme that converts how to
cyanide too far behind and I was really
was really proud of that accomplishment
but I but there's another message here
in this one and that is that your
audience really matters it turns out the
audience for cyanogenic work in plants
and very small as well as stated here my
first phytopathology paper on xen that
must be 19 okay cyanide tolerant since
I'm feeling low tide since 1971 has had
15 of citations my first paper on Fatah
confessed ends of 1975 and 7 950 which
is interesting three or four and last
six months which is also the most
impressive paper certainly with HD and I
published was in archives and falconers
from of physics and it's had my
citations again nothing the past three
or four months my most highly cited
paper on fight off infestans is this one
in 1994 but we just started a global
distribution of a single from a lineage
in campus with 437 citations and 20 in
the last seven points which is different
so the message here that there was an
audience for my pudding excellent
working sun identity but there was an
audience for work on my top ten
pheasants I have to say this paper yeah
I know demonstration
the obvious then yet was it was picked
up by ok so I was hired and saw this
picture for was hired to teach Disease
Control and you appropriate research and
with my background in the plant
physiology and biochemistry that seemed
like his stretch and it was I really
know put in the world I would be going
to do so I thought long and hard about
it it has started the position was
actually here and what I decided to do
was too focused on late blood for a
variety of reasons first of all it was a
model for secondly it was important in
New York State it was possible to me to
do field experiments and there was
expertise in department warrant credit
when credit digs Thurston who was
remarkably generous with advice and help
during the early stages and he had been
working with phytother Festus but
required some time I thought he was old
at that time but he was pretty very
helpful so that was the reason I chose
it all right some epidemiology and
population genetics studies when i first
started work at secret do you think that
i would really have to do some few
experiments
management my first field experiment
occurred in 1917 tubes a total boss
we've got drowned out from Hurricane
Agnes our second field experiment was of
a lunar month later in the same year
there was absolutely no disease and I
realized that this is not easy as
packaging in the world to work with
subsequently moved to frito and did
learn how to do field experiments with
white tough investments this is narrow
photo of those plots and it's a false
color infrared photo and the healthy
tissue looks bright red diseased tissue
gray or in soil sort of three so there
were really significant differences in
these and listen buddy actually found an
interesting to do these kinds of
experiments because there were almost
analogous to doing enzyme assays just
how many people have ever done enzyme
assays artistic a couple of us old folks
right and we [ __ ] that anymore but I
did and the kinetics were very
interesting and aziz development is one
of these plots had kinetics that work in
use and there's really good really
develop over time in kinetics were
really quite important so what we knew
about the epidemiology of phytophthora
des des was really quite a lot and Jack
Brown in 1981 published a paper
describing a simulation model cartoon of
it you listed here and clean enough to
put this too
after it which was a really interesting
accomplished a person to run this model
took hours and hours actually first time
we get up is on punch card to the
mainframe but we use in two experiments
over the weekend and come back and we
have a simulation experiment to do the
same experiment today takes less than a
second and Jorge entrada refine the
model in 2005 and illustrated that
really works pretty well in these
various epidemics the observations are
in the open circles and the prediction
is in the straight continuous line and
you can see that the prediction fits the
observation pretty nicely in most of
these and that model has been the basis
for decision support system that we've
subsequently produced students this
paper by in small from last year in
which we named and use the white pro
decision support system and that's
really kind of cool it involves host
resistance password future whether such
a side a pathogen strain and pathogen
proximity all together in helping
growers make management decisions and
what's really important i think is that
all this is done in absentia so it's
it's a it's a very nice tool what we
didn't know at that time was what caused
unexpected disease control
and we wondered about whether the
University of the pathogen population
might contribute to that and so we began
the question looking at population
genetics and photos and festivals and
when we started this we knew that there
were a 2 and a 1 many types in Mexico
what topic of Stanton's head without so
there are too many times he wanted
nature and only a one mating types had
been found from the rest of the world so
two people coming to lab would already
had wonderful tools totally brought
allozyme stir that followed by Steve
good one who developed here rflp
fingerprint for DNA fingerprinting I
slits prior to this time the only
markers that were available for mating
type and morphology no diversity in
mythology so we only had meeting type
essentially single market and that
because you just been joking about
populations of plant pathogens from that
these these two games a possibility of
looking at population structure and
disorganization in other locations so we
so requested Isis from people around the
world some culture collections and
analyze those isolates using both
markets and we felt like Paul Dooley and
markers developed by Steve good way in
Mexico what we learned is that indeed
the a1 and a2 mating types were present
proportions when we applied the dusties
do they think creativity's what we
learned is that the population of rivers
and with this slide illustrates these
these numbers real estate those three
individual individuals the DNA is in
this lady's cup with restriction
fragment restriction enzyme and then
probe with our fee 57 and what you'll
see is that these individual states are
really quite different from each other
which is consistent with this being a
sexual population in central Mexico what
we learned from everywhere else was
something we need to management and so
does affirming US Canada Peru Ecuador
Colombia the UK Netherlands going to
pantalon Philippines can under wanted
all had the same paper which was a
really interesting with occupation we
termed this photo lineage the US 1
formal image if you saw it first in the
US and s are everywhere else it's all it
would maybe type in one type of
mitochondrial DNA of the Allison's
lurkin 112 had the same DNA fingerprint
and as always pop out pretty to this
paper doll talk about the panworld with
mr. grade distribution of a single
linning to flip out that residents
how can you explain that kind of
situation nobody can explain it for sure
but one possibility is that this
organism went through a severe
bottleneck and when somehow to northwest
europe in northwest europe there's a
very vibrant seed particular trait or
secret a toner sold all over the world
to South America Africa Asia and this
organism most very happily tubers
another possibility is that it came
first to the United States and in fact
make life appeared in the United States
before it appeared in Europe and then
maybe from the United States it went to
Europe and then subsequently was
distributed throughout the rest of the
world so those are some possibilities
but we continue collecting knife slips
from people around the world and linda
Spielman made a really interesting
discovery she said look there's
something else happening in these
locations around the world and so sure
enough there was and what we suggested
is that there was a second worldwide
migration and population this is some of
the most exciting work that ever been
associated probably some of the most
important i wrote a spectacular proposal
to the best
traction which is really interesting so
it seems like some of the most important
and most interesting projects to still
make it so that the reviewers where he
didn't like it and they didn't believe
that this could be happening but in fact
it did it made the news in the early
1990s there is an article from New York
Times and this is what actually happened
in the 1970s us one was disputed
essentially all around the world by 1997
those populations have been replaced you
can't find it anymore locations can find
that particular video it's been replaced
by a different population of veterans
which is highly diverse in those
locations and actually there's sexual
reproduction occurring in in the
Scandinavian countries and we do know
how that happened there was a shipment
of potatoes from Mexico after the 1976
season because in New York there had
been a drought in the 1976's a very
short potato crop and Europeans desire
to allow Mexican potatoes into Europe so
that we use exclusively for
you can't forget people who buy potatoes
store from planting and I'm sure that's
what happened and that's what brought in
these novel strains if I talk they're
testing and then they were substrate
from northwestern Europe and it happened
really fast he didn't have Isis in the
Netherlands Germany and Poland we could
cut the deck and we can demonstrate that
this there was this introduction of the
new strings and they displaced the old
spines that had been and so this message
I guess is that with this organism
vibration and population displacement
are really cute and it didn't happen
only in Europe it also happened in the
States here's an example that is
particularly impressive to me and this
concerns a lineage that we've called the
u.s. 800m lineage we detected it in 1992
and watch new computer
season at the invite season we had a
sample from Maine which also had that
which gives him astray before because
we've sampled from Northwest Mexico and
found this exactly president in a
Northwest Mexico and then in 1994 you
covered the entire eastern part of the
US and by 1995 could colonize all of the
western part of the u.s. so one of the
things that we've done is to look at the
population structure over time and this
slide prepared by Giovanni Johnny's
illustrates that us eight was the
dominant strain from 1997 to 2008
replaced in 2009 by us 22 now they just
wondered throughout that and then you
can see that after 2010 that US 23 has
become the dominant strain and this
turns out to be really difficult for
fight often festivals is that there are
these waves of predominance and
disappearance and it's not is to not
only in the US but also in Europe and
these are data from people who
illustrates that the u.s. one strains
present 1982 were gone by 1995 and then
these a one stranger present until about
two thousand five and starting in 2005
there was dominance by destroyed here
which of blue 13 or 13 a2 and that
and so the take-home message concerning
epidemiology and population turns to me
is that all non Mexicans Mexican
phytophthora infestans populations are
recently derived from outside this
organs we just goes in lots of places
I've seen reports where people have
suggested that we have an Irish
stringing a fight off Manchester what
they don't say so we've been there for
10 years and prior to that it was in
Mexico would you say there's no way that
there is such a thing as an Irish
straight there's no way that there's
such a thing as the US as a nuestra
they're all recently arrived from okay
so my next topic is about humanity
I took this picture in early August 1994
and this is a potato form and this is a
potato field and its ground because it
was destroyed by that light and this is
a sprayer right here in that car engine
spray two or three times a week to
suppress lately so I talked on the
grower
this is always difficult to say
about where you could
and he said every Thursday night the
growers in this county pitfield in
Crimea
and that's because I think we're other
customers i think this strain would you
just relax all
spin dramatically more aggressive
you just wrote on a customer
so that was Sir my first introduction to
the damage and human impact that this
disease
it's a picture of Irish happened he was
a blower in Madison County and in
nineteen metaphor he lost his problems
these are dead he said illustrating but
late blight 1990 94 in 1995 bankruptcy
and a clean nurse later he died
we 2009 of similar story having this
really fascinating Kevin Myers in my
life took this picture at our local
Lowe's to this picture and gene 23rd
these are explained of transfers to be
sold to local garters and they are
infected with Python third persons and
what happened was what happened not only
in our Louis but New Jersey and
Pennsylvania in Connecticut in Maine all
throughout the Northeast and a visit to
this organic farm I think forget of july
in 2009 and this was the lat plenty of
tomatoes and they would be deterred by
the lake life as well and i received
this letter which i think Bob's me I am
an organic gardener in Amsterdam New
York with 63 heirloom tomato plants and
23 different varieties they're all gone
I was growing very rare varieties blacks
being oranges whites I'll purchase from
a very reputable brands of Harry can I
have believed home as my husband pulling
that you all 63 plants I have a her
percent loss we know on 10 acres I
inspected every day and it seems the
black took my defense in a matter of
hours I was hoping to sell them for
additional people so on this as I chose
late blight to work on as an academic
convenient system to use I've heard
about all this snow from the Irish
potato famine at all but to experience
is really really quite significant and
this side was given to me by san jo
Illinois it was an example of a 2014
lake in west bengal in india and what
happened there was that in 2013 Melvin's
significant overproduction at mid to low
prices and centaurs could not be the
motorcade in 2014 there was a
devastating Lakeland epidemic caused by
13 in Europe there were term Eliza's
economic and social amend farmer
suicides and then some toys particularly
disappointed that the government or he
is limited exports to other places
because that sort of distorted future
markets for the growers of our
communities so my lesson that I've taken
from this one is that light line okay
next on to host-pathogen interactions is
my third topic
message and label this one of the fryer
lab failures and is their failures
because we've been unable to see
phenotypes that other folks see the
first one concerns on purified Osment in
which according to the pnas article
confer resistance so we've received the
developers of is we're happy to send us
transgenic potatoes that were expressed
in PR card we put them in the field this
is an experiment where we had different
potatoes genotypes and unfortunately the
plants with pr5 we're not at all
resistant just completely not so that's
you know we just could not achieve the
same result that the folks at Purdue
energy and then a year to later
conversation
colleague in Europe and she said I've
created resistance to lately I said wow
that's great the company and they were
going to create transgenic potatoes that
were resistant to late life and
unfortunately were able to do a test
which confirmed that experiment and this
is a picture of that field experiment
there's some people to know who were
part of that experiment and remember it
well and by this time I've learned how
to kill plants inflate boy and although
the company would never come across or
convinced that what happened the concert
had a pathogen specific promoter with an
arching and a navy argue so that upon
our NOC ulation of leave with quite
often pest hands we make hypersensitive
response and resistance and I think
that's what they saw in their
experiments of Europe so this is a just
after we had an occupation and this is
what we saw after the
progressive turns out there was indeed
diversity in the transgenders someone
more resistant somewhere less there is
nothing associated that was diversity so
one of the things I really don't think
this is that if you put potatoes to a
palace reduce the laughter's summer funk
very much and that explains the person
that you'll see the question is why why
do some people see these these
phenotypes that week and I wanted that
for some years and then just in the last
couple of years I think I think I
actually know and I think the answer is
at sporangia from a culture are not the
same as spread year from leading
colleges and people inoculate the growth
chamber with Sturridge of the culture an
epidemic in the field
so the reason I think I know this comes
in part with work from headquarters in
routine water was this his approach was
to his goal was to look at how sensitive
my toughest had spread to our to solar
radiation and you he had a terrible time
he was one of her happy register for the
summer because every time he did this
experiment you take the spreadsheet from
culturing expose them to someone
absolutely no surprise finally a
desperation when he didn't have a
culture available he took some spreading
from the leaf and long before they
didn't copy conditions 87 survived for
hours mm-hmm under sunny conditions
which is illustrated here most of their
dead within 60 minutes but they survived
15 minutes installation so clearly the
sporangia from this culture army which
don't survive at all spend you from the
juicer god they're pretty different from
each other they work with then closing
we had another insight into this dan was
working on arachidonic acid and where he
demonstrated that in fact retreat plans
of arachidonic acid to become more
resistant to phytophthora infestans
which is just great and here's an image
of that here is a leaflet that did not
have our economic acid applied to it and
you can see nice lesion here's a leaflet
that did have our epidemic acid and the
is a very small regional population but
we tried to repeat that experiment and
the same and then I realize the reason
we didn't get that phenotype is that we
were taking our spray get from papers
and inoculate so if you take a
scrounging from a leaflet and you put it
on to plants treated either treat not
treated with arachidonic acid or treated
with our economic acid um again it's
this exact same pathogen one comes from
leaf the other comes from so one of the
questions that Shawn parties was asking
is is there an effective dist
pathogenicity and he did a field
experiment in which he took sprang from
the culture two different isolates and
inoculated plants in the field and
leaflets in moisture and you can see
that he did get disease different
amounts of disease from the two isolates
if he took sporangia from a leaflet both
in the field pots for both isolates
you've got a lot more disease the same
numbers branch then he did if the ISIS
came from culture and that's
particularly true with the disease on
leafless in moisture
so our goal is to try to understand what
what is happening and one approach is to
use our NAC to determine first of all if
this branch are different from each
other and secondly to see what's
happening during the infection process
those materials are still at while
they're going to come back we don't have
them yet so in lieu of having the RNA
seek data Sean did some one day in real
time pcr and what we know is that
infamous elicited by talking to us today
that's a protein if you put it into
tobacco it's a hypersensitive response
we know that that smoothie indeed
elicited is downregulated in Infante oh
there is an RX lr that which is an
effector from photographer investor from
previous studies we knew that one to be
upregulated in in tissue and so what we
did was to compare the expression of
these two genes in spreads that came
from the leaves or from culture and what
we found was that from culture info on
which causes hundred
the are XLR which is an effector was
definitely so what Ron did was to look
at the ratio of inform the expression of
if one to the expression of our XLR
between spreads that came from culture
or sprint to the king from leaflets and
what he found is that for these two
isolates there's about a more than a
50-fold difference in expression of
those teachers and our suspect that that
difference in expression can cause a
different phenotype if you're using a
strange infant culture person system
so the pathogen clearly is different
what about the host but that is in
different environments and it turns out
i think that the host also be different
we did this experiment last year right
now 2000 one or two thousand or two
dozen three something like that and
chris was heavily involved in this one
we were looking at the differences in
resistor between two closely related
tomato compressions but we did find a
QTL for resistance and what was wrong
about this he's at first of all we could
get fairly expression and without a
whole lot of noise which mr. interested
we used micro thomas is old technology
that but one of the most interesting to
me discoveries for plants that were not
inoculated just growing together what we
found was that the top 34 of the top 200
most variable we're all defensively
and what I'm wondering is are they in
fact divest really are they just are
they just perturbation in destroying in
the field over here exposed to all kinds
of things and the top six included
catalase which is the first one and then
five PR team concluded the most variable
strains of arabic genes in this
experiment we also found a significant
differential expression of genes in the
two different two different genotypes of
planets and we found that we were able
to science to of about thirty two they
were upregulated in il-62 but not i may
need to get maybe two of us and more
susceptible when we silenced those two
it reduce the resistance in il-6 to the
conclusion i come to is that field
expertise of field studies of gene
expression are entirely possible and
there's not a huge amount of noise you
don't have to always get a huge amount
of very sore throat and i'm just going
to suggest that if we really are
interested in post per second version
that's happening sort of a field that is
a whole lot more efficient to do this
kind of experiment
so the third message I have concerning
post-crescent interactions is that may
be at least r500 distance and its host
the interaction can be specific so
finally the three messages to me are
there is no such thing except in Supreme
Mexico the native african fest and late
blight can be absolutely true and we
also get with it can be specific to the
environment now this is a maverick micro
I'm on my good friend Cindy McNabb
developed this Limerick phytophthora
infestans is freaking prototypical also
quite speaking its maverick waves cause
eyebrows to raise in theories turn
porous and linking sometimes it textbook
quintessential exemplary so elemental
that's when it conforms to microbial
norms a model that's quite providential
sometimes it's in freakin weird a
renegade has reappeared starts breaking
rules making us look like fools
conclusive results disappear this model
that's this micro that's model and
maverick exemplary and enigmatic we must
understand learned by both and eccentric
yet paradigm so I'd like to thank you
also to recognize this group of people
through my work I don't have pictures of
everybody this time but i would like to
Lisa Christmas in the audience now over
there oh if I'd my wife Barbara is here
she works in the lab and has been a big
partner so I think with that homeless
and there's already questions of being
happy to try to dust so you found that
things like sporangia or resistance or
variable
parameters
uh that's I think the matching the model
does need to be recalibrated what we
learned is that different isolates have
different parameters most models are
constructed on the US for money the
capability of those models is very not
known at this point to how useful they
are I think what we saw was sort of a
qualitative difference in terms of in
terms of the
field versus the greenhouse type of
direction but this problems intestinal
exclusively or not specific a lot in the
field so I think that has helped us a
lot so your take-home message number one
is that all the isolates that we know of
today came from Mexico if they're all
moving about we're giving these new
epidemics with new genotypes presumably
you get different mating types that move
out and then you could get
geographically specific isil's right
when do you think that's you think it's
already happening yeah it's happening
there's um there's a sexual population
in Scandinavian countries and probably
poland i still need Olivia western
Russia and whether that will develop
into something dramatically different
all right ah in many places it's still
hiding from traumatic apologists like it
is in the United States the all of
Africans that way India Asia are that
way South America is that way
so there's there's its initiative
actually I mean there is sexual
reproduction in that part of the world
including the step but most other
locations have clonal lineages and
someone said the same one like this blue
13 which is found in Europe is now
dominant in China and so just as the
follow-up to that so for places where
the populations are clonal quarantine
issues seem to be key you're not going
to get a diverse population there unless
you unless you allow entry of new
isolates right right but this pathogen
travels on potatoes around the world and
it travels in the air as well so I think
there will be there is migration quite
quite
sexual
so I'm in actual potatoes were not
ground commercially and potatoes until
the nineteen existence prior to that
time it was on wild species but now
there's a hell of a lot of time decided
to use one commercial potatoes
so
stint little in tune with the value some
actually doesn't because of such a
diverse population it doesn't to look at
any single
but elsewhere pretend oh USA we saw in
the Los Mochis very similar state
forensic officer anyway so I'm curious
about the transgenic AVR our gene
potatoes nice all kind of go down did
that look like a typical disease or to
DC signs of autoimmunity or a
temperature it look really typical like
life we thought there was no fee
associated
this is so cool so when is it puts up
with the future so Jonathan ours on the
state of the jonathan Jones one time you
saying that our teams have you need the
very best thing since sliced bread and I
got before that and said they're never
gonna work so what what what's really
cool is that if you combine the effect
of an arching with the fungicide that
will make the RG a lot more durable and
Simplot company is doing that you know
they have transgenic plants with our
genes they want those plans to receive a
little fungicide because as Michael
Milgram has demonstrated if you suppress
selection then you delay the demise of a
particular RG and what way to do that is
to use a small amount of thunder second
edition so I think I think it's going to
be integrated management and I think
that's what's gonna happen if anybody
amazing your elders in Geneva have
questioned
to do we don't have anybody else here
bill will help please go ahead
are you know so sexual recombination
creates new genotypes and mutation is
the source of those of that diversity so
we know that my toddler changes the law
for example in a single lineage there
can be a whole bunch of diversity for
effectors that are recognized by but
what we do see is you do get tremendous
more genotypic diversity in a sexual
population than and a central partners
but we have honey clonal populations in
most of the early well well we want to
recognize you and thank you again for
really else
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu